Hold on hard,
I'm going to tell you.
1 of the most controversial initiatives that we started in this 2
024 And now if you are walking through the streets of London or
the streets of the United Kingdom and you are illegally you could
end up in 1 couple of hours in 1 plane to Africa exactly to Rouen.
The House of Commons has just given the green light to that
controversial bill to deport illegal immigrants or such applicants to Africa,
but this is not new.
This initiative had been taken by former Prime Minister Boris Johnson,
but in November last year the UK Supreme Court had stopped that.
The truth is that this is not free.
Rwanda received more than 240 million for accepting the UK's favor.
Now it is enough to wait for Prime Minister
Richi Sunak to set a date and time fors to Rwanda.
And but I would like to ask you,
do you think it is normal that you arrive in 1 country in the case of asylum
seekers in search of security and end up in
another continent in another country?
And remember that in my channel I found 1 video dedicated to
this situation and others that are happening here in Europe
because I understand that it is not only the United Kingdom but
there are countries in Europe already negotiating with Rwanda to
send their asylum seekers and their immigrants More information below.